I'll tell ya I'm the government - River
welcome back to Anna the artistic that's
a nice name too but it's a biochip so
that's how the house looks like doesn't
really look like that does it well we
are back in the darkness I don't know
what I did last time I think I forgot to
put pick you up and I think while I'm at
it
I have a cheat or anything if you think
that I owe that were your nipples
nipples like the week that's fine
girl I'm not gonna ask any questions
about your nipple but this was squared
shape let's see
rectangular ah sorry a rectangular I
guess it
and there's electric tangle so let's
combine it and letting beste Gate the
Narnia two mountains with which I am
well acquainted castle and Pollux or the
twins I am in such recital is Salman
face
I've been told that if you press H it's
gonna give you a clue but it doesn't
[ __ ] work shout out my back this game
just kind of stopped making sense as
soon as you enter the house as my
opinion but yeah some sawdust why not I
want to snap that [ __ ] I'll just get
some of that I can get that
what about disk Esther hmm we can't pick
up the cast room not even as I had
planned
what about here how do we get planned I
don't I don't get it I think what we'll
do is spread out some sawdust on the
water how about here sawdust on the
water Masada's is the pulse sitting and
on transparent bridge it is now visible
also that's why there's a shadow there
it all makes sense now
who would think of that I did think of
that I'm a genius
don't worry the anus is really creepy in
this game nothing really happens oh I
can walk in cool how about I pick you up
what is this examine how odd how odd in
the central the future parlor is a gap
in the sludge the water that looks up
here I could drink it well why don't we
just [ __ ] drink it then no why
oh well [ __ ] you then I did my idea
never worry
snip rip around this nipple Reaper super
shooter on the snippet what if this
sawmill no one like something anything
I gotta get some more of that dust I'll
just get some of that
I'll just get double that night pull out
a hill and put some more out I my what
am i doing
can you combine oh my god the two pages
fit perfectly and I just build some sort
of ritual dagger
your nipple sir your nipple I'm glad you
updated me on that information girl that
makes me happy now take some sawdust why
not it works over here why would God
yeah alright what I do with this burn it
something that won't work what is it a
heap oh okay there's more than one how
could you think of that what I don't
[ __ ] know
I want to cheat I want to cheat bras I
don't know what the [ __ ] did L brought
about with stab pins on stir it stab it
how could you think of that all right I
got a cheat all right we're back yep
I didn't cheat on anything the image of
a snake is apparently that is fantastic
now I can stab the water because that
makes so much [ __ ] sense I little
catch it big enough
Davis is like what whoa whoa
I'm not cool with that don't laugh at me
when I ask you a question how did you do
that wizard I'm not running it's Felix
Felix Kjellberg know what do I do now I
pick it up
we're gonna use this by the way I cut
the road I got five leave now
cool all right I don't remember
[ __ ] supposed to do with this son of
a [ __ ] let's stab them again it mags
now Jen Savage what y'all
yeah stabbing one time that makes sense
stab you two times that is just
ridiculous I mean why could you think of
it
Oh Oh mr. Chad you see it do you see
this mr. chair
what are you doing anyway what is this
examine there's a niche car into the
wall I didn't know what an ish is
something drawn inside that's fantastic
what it oh they are glowing and they are
happy about it
ah yeah the creature glowing it seemed
and Brust
that's cool what about you I shouldn't
you already told me that there's
something drawn inside whoa oh oh it
went down didn't it
well don't care me what should I do
what'd I do
don't kill me son a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
don't kill me don't kill me whoever
you're here to kill me out oh don't kill
me I got ya I got I don't need ya all
right what is what is up with this
something changed and thanks out
okay it's okay
no no what did I do
I'm sorry I'm sorry I can change I
didn't tell you anything
shut up ja I dragged a black click it
because I'm not hungry
oh I'm on my period
Everland what Oh No oh hello oh hello
hello oh hello what ahead circle
hello house now plunging things house
now Casta hell's am house yes all in
water saw this
well whoa whoa don't kill me
guitar wow my alone here I don't get it
the death was black the Hitchin bronze
the happiness golden the solitude
silvery get the soul I was white a lame
lame Italian so lame
I just want to skate I just can't go
ahead it looks like death to me like
salmon they don't tell you [ __ ] you
what about the other ones hey go you
can't run in this game I'm gonna walk
like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright what this would be this looks
like death to me I don't give you any
[ __ ] please do there
all right I was out at happiness this is
like this guy looks pretty pimp I don't
know but this gotta be happening alright
which one is happiness golden of course
I'm a genius
alright happiness you I will give it to
you
alright put that oh I get it
I hope this is happening that look how
happy they are about the trees and I
tells ya trees [ __ ]
alright the Deaf was black a solitary
know the bombings yet the sole lie was
white
hatred was bronze hatred and death it's
kind of difficult this could be hatred
though that guy looks up babies like
hell yeah I got a buck Becca oh he's got
a book we're angry that's well was
hatred bronze alright [ __ ] my memory
bronze leaf there you go you are welcome
the lie what's the happiness hatred
hatred hatred hatred hate red hatred
whoa whoa don't kill me what what's
doing that we're not gonna wipe in da
bed coming from here boom
[ __ ] your door [ __ ] your door [ __ ] yeah
you think you're funny huh stop it that
job scaring me like that
ah I sweater got it they did a proper
scare in this game I would [ __ ] my pants
because they really you don't expect it
but it's not just not that type of game
that's okay that's okay there's gotta be
there's gotta be deaf right I think I
got the other one oh this piece of shits
alright what is this it's gotta be deaf
to I Street II suppose did EULA wait
who's more done deaf and hatred no we
didn't agent
[ __ ] but this gotta be deaf ton of dead
people deaf got to be black shut up game
I can't get dead black go black go black
a blue there we go
you're not looking at my penis anymore
as I know peeping hole all right we got
silver and the two things I don't know
what the [ __ ] they mean solitude got a
look that word up I'm sorry her social
isolation or loneliness ah [ __ ] I could
be this one kidney
she's chemist oh no I know I know this
is the line that I was lying
this is a lie that will this line this
is the lad this is a latitude to do do
do do re that's how I roll that's how I
get you're the lady that's how I don't
never get on a lady that I wrote that
how I did or lady that I rolled it up
that that that that our roles is how I
get on a lady that viral how'd I get it
oh and she's solid too because all alone
and everyone is little dead I'm a genius
please work please please
you're never my table no no no
no no yeah yes Wow Wow all right and I
think it will only be one more episode
of this um it's kind of short game
I would probably wouldn't offend it keep
playing if it's like super long but
since it's so short I just it's a pretty
creepy experience I want to keep playing
it's uh and I don't know let me know
what do you best think it said it's not
that bad it's just that some of the
puzzles just don't [ __ ] make sense at
all yeah anyway like video fish enjoyed
the sky camera day now scene exceptional
oh boy ever our makes tales I don't like
it
alright fine ran dry rag hot [ __ ] I mess
with the face right never laughs never
double never twist
that's how I roll in this fashion Tim's
back